so the chart that you're looking at
right now is called the fear greet index
and here's all it is
when we're extremely greedy
fear is very low and when we're
extremely afraid greed is very low what
does this really mean so if for example
a year ago in a marketplace everybody
was super greedy they had money they
were making money in crypto in the stock
market tesla bitcoin ethereum nfts
everybody was super super greedy so they
were not afraid they were not worried
about what the market's going to look
like they were walking around saying i
got money in the bank i got half a
million in crypto i got a million
dollars here i got two million dollars
here and they're very comfortable with
where they are so they're not
open-minded they're not looking they
think they know it all they got a
million and one blind spots and we've
all been there before and then all of a
sudden they get hit hard and you notice
greed gradually comes down and fear
gradually comes up so if i were to ask
you right now let's play a game
if you look at this chart again where do
you think we are right now with the fear
greed index
do you think we're at level one which is
the highest highest greed and the lowest
level fear do you think we're somewhere
between greed being high and greed being
in the middle with fear tied up do you
think kind of we're quarter way do you
think we're halfway do you think we're
already super afraid or extremely afraid
where do you think we are i'm willing to
tell you
we are right now in between extremely
greedy and somewhat leveling off right
in the middle between fear i think we're
quarter uh ways there and why am i
saying this because people still have
record-breaking savings in the bank
yes people lost three trillion dollars
in retirement savings yes 80 000 crypto
millionaires were wiped out and you know
they're still you know worried about
what happened with their bitcoin they're
waiting for it to come up a little bit
ethereum's been coming up a little bit
yes that took place
but people are still a little bit greedy
fear hasn't sunk in yet the video i did
with real estate you know how many
reaction videos was made about the real
estate video market crash video you're
wrong
you don't know what you're talking about
there's no way this is going to happen
there's no way here's what we're going
to do they just announced today that
they're raising the you know interest
rates again another three bases three
quarters of a basis point and their
quote when they say about uh raising the
interest rates is the same exact thing
they're raising the three-quarters of a
basis point uh but they don't know if
they're going to do it again the future
because economists are not aware they've
been saying this every month but they're
not going to do it but they're not going
to do it again even yesterday white
house is talking about the recession
it's not really recession it's not
really recession this is not really the
definitions change uh a person asks the
press secretary are you guys trying to
change the definition of recession you
know what she finally answered she says
i'm not answering any questions about
recession why not
it's what everybody wants to know it was
the trending word on twitter yesterday
recession is trending on twitter if
recession is trending on twitter what do
you think america's thinking right now
maybe we are in recession so if you can
time this
it's very basic
timing part when people are greedy
terrible time to buy when people are
afraid great time to buy the key is to
time when people are the most afraid and
it ain't today because people are still
greedy today people are still sitting
there saying my real estate is going to
come back up bitcoin is going to come
back up stock market's going to come
back up meaning it's going to come back
up right now obviously it's eventually
going to come back up but it's like oh
it's going to come back up in the next
90 days in the next six months
this thing we're in right now is going
to last a minute is it going to last
four years i don't know is it going to
last six months i don't know but
historically last six months to 43
months and the one that lasted 43 months
was called the great depression and the
one last six months has been many
different recessions that we've had but
regardless if it's six months only
and if recession started july 1st that
means worst case scenario recession is
going to go till when august september
october november december january 1st
the least this thing is going to go is
till the end of january the longest it's
going to go it's going to be until 2025
maybe 2026 that's the longest but that's
the range that we have and for you is to
watch the marketplace a mickey mantle
card hit the marketplace yesterday sgc
nine and a half some say that's a 15
million dollar card some say that's a 25
million dollar card some say it's a 30
million dollar card some say it's a 5
million card the fear index is going to
show right now what people think it's
worth if it's sold 6 months from now i
guarantee you it would be a lot less
than it is today that's my speculation
on what i think would happen
but people if they're still paying high
prices people are still greedy today
which means today is probably still not
the best time to buy the best time to
buy is probably going to be next 3 6 12
months from now i may be wrong but i
think we're still not there yet so again
whenever you look at investments or
whenever you want to buy stuff ask
yourself how greedy are we today how
afraid are we today when fear is high
sales are higher appointment shows
higher people are more receptive they
want to listen to what you have to offer
when greed is high they don't take your
calls they don't take the meetings they
only give you five minutes they you know
blow you off it takes them five times to
get to meetings so you can always
measure when we're greedy when we're
afraid and based on that you can make
the decisions for yourself now if this
video got you thinking give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel and i
got two videos i want you to watch one
of them is if you're concerned about
what's going to happen to real estate
bubble watch this video and if you're
worried about the stock market crash
click to watch this video take care
everybody bye